is it really surprising that the most  powerful man in the world should be a  figure of controversy we as a population  on this planet have been looking for a  savior nature we're talking about a baby  whose very existence is not telling us  the truth challenges our own sense of  priority in the universe human beings  have a horrible track record of  following people with great power an  absolute power corrupts absolutely chaos  maybe he's just a guy trying to do the  right they know better now don't matter  Devil's don't come up with what he can  do that no one has asked what he should  that's how it starts the fever the rage  the feeling of powerlessness that turns  good men  fool  tell me do you bleed  riddle  you